hey guys just want to make a quick video
talking about the patreon and the
changes i've made there i know i've
changed it a lot in the past but i think
i'm just going to stick with this it
seems
uh fine for now um the only thing that
might change is the limited slots
all right so let's just start at the top
the silver tier is the lowest tier if
you just want to support the channel you
can join on that and you get access to
all the patreon posts
six dollar tier is the same you get some
special role in discord discord role
doesn't really mean a whole lot to be
honest but if you want it you can get it
you get a little little badge next to
you or whatever
all right cool
so these are just general support levels
at uh the 10 and up that's when i start
putting you at the end of videos when i
roll the credits on a video
i'll say shout out to these patrons
that's the 10 and up
tier so
that's that and the next one is is the
15 one
it's the same thing you get a shout out
but also i'm going to give you access to
some of my private source code i am
still developing ancient archer
the one that's publicly available i
haven't worked on in quite a while the
one i'm working on now is
version two
i also have this piece of software
called dmpower that i privately work on
so it's mainly access to those
two repos
and uh yeah you'll just get the latest
of what's going on there now uh we get
to the the higher tiers the 25 there's
i'm limiting these for now i might raise
the limit depending i need to figure out
my workload once these slots get filled
basically because this one starts
offering one-on-one
access to me and this is
just for like ama a little private
discussion you want to ask me questions
or whatever it's almost like the
tutoring to be honest but i'm not gonna
screen share with you i'll probably just
hop in a chat with you uh
i i don't know it's a little open it's
it's not specifically tutoring but if i
guess you ask me questions and i know
the answer i'll probably answer
but uh or whatever you want to do maybe
you just want to do your own podcast and
you want me to join you for an hour and
just ask me stuff for i don't know
whatever you want to do
that kind of thing and the 50
a month ones where i actually do like a
real
meeting with you if you need help with
some assignment you don't understand for
school or something you think i know how
to do it
uh this is the one you want or if you're
doing something for work and it involves
something i do all the time like cmake
or
any of that stuff c plus and you just
need like help figuring out the code
this is where we can screen share and we
can walk through things
and i'll troubleshoot with you now these
are
per month if you want more than like one
hour per month
maybe you want a weekly or something
we're gonna have to make some other deal
some other way so
just throwing that all out there that's
what the tears are that's their
intention they're purely to support this
channel and just support me
and help make this business viable
i will speak briefly on
the youtube stuff too let me look at
that i'm going to bring that up
okay so the youtube membership the join
button
it's uh it's a little looser
there isn't uh
there isn't all the same benefits as
patreon because well it's really hard to
synchronize them there isn't really a
good way to synchronize them the main
thing you get is you get these loyalty
badges in the chat and when you comment
and when i start doing live streams and
stuff
if i see a member
chat i'm going to focus on their
question more that's the biggest thing
so at the lowest level it's just to
support the channel get you a badge you
can join the code gang all right it's
three bucks and then there's a ten
dollar one that is code warrior it's not
really any different you just you just
get this slayer of algo's thing in your
comment that's that's basically what you
get and then just shut up and take my
money i don't know i was just memen so
if you really like the channel and you
want to donate more and you want
everyone to know you're a cash cow you
can
you can join that tier if you want
access to the source code and all the
the one-on-one stuff patreon's better i
think youtube gives me a better
cut of your money that makes sense
patreon thinks takes a little more so if
you're just purely interested in only
supporting me and you don't you don't
want to try to meet up or whatever or do
anything else special
these are probably a little better for
that hopefully i can
continue this channel and keep it
sustainable that is really the main goal
and if you have any questions let me
know
down below
and you might also ask okay why do you
do all this as an ad revenue enough and
i guess i can speak on that just briefly
because i'm sure people are wondering
well overall well things are okay
i'm pretty suitable for ads
and i seem to be able to put ads on all
my videos and i keep them relatively
clean for that reason however my channel
is not at any kind of level where i can
quit my normal
job or stop doing other things and focus
on the channel i make about 200 a month
which is excellent considering
uh let's see if i go to like i don't
know just want to be open about this
so i'm not trying to hide anything you
know it started at some point and at
first i was making like
20 30 and it's been steadily kind of
increasing over time which is pretty
normal for a youtube channel once you
get monetized if you keep making content
it tends to increase slowly over time so
i do expect this number to slowly keep
rising uh hopefully crossing fingers
and i'll keep trying to produce content
that is valuable to you guys for that
reason
but obviously
nobody
especially in america at least
can live in 200 a month that's enough
for like
some groceries so now it's enough to
fill my gas tank maybe it's enough to
maybe pay part by internet bill it's
it's not
unfortunately not even close to enough
to pay all my rent and all that stuff so
that's why this is still a side gig for
me until we reach
a certain threshold and that's why the
patreon and the join button that's why
all that stuff is there basically
because yeah quite literally i do need
it to support the channel to be
perfectly honest if we're
if we're just
being really
blatantly honest about things like
what i make now is not even enough to
continue producing videos to be honest
because most videos
i think i explained this in the video
that i called quitting youtube where i
quit or something like that
it's it's almost enough to produce one
video what i make currently almost not
quite so i'm basically doing this
somewhat for free even still that being
the case i really have no remorse if i
have to
jump ship because it's like i don't
really have a whole lot
to lose it's like i'm making a little
but
it's not exactly sustaining me i
this was all i did
and all i had
i would be out on the street in a month
and uh yeah that's just the reality of
it so i don't want to i know a lot of
people
get the impression if they see someone
on youtube that they're making millions
it's not the case it's been
almost
two years and i've made
three thousand dollars in and two years
that's like
it was about a thousand dollars the
first year a little less thousand
dollars a little more the second year
and sure it's going to keep increasing
but it's not going to hit a sustainable
level at this growth rate until i'm
retired basically and then it'll be like
all right i'm retired what's the point
now i won't be working anymore probably
i don't know what i'll be doing who
knows
but the point is the growth is so slow
that it's not really a reasonable career
path sure i could sell out and take
every ad sponsorship and yell raid
shadow legends at you guys and stuff
like that
but i refuse to do that i flat out
refuse to take sponsorships for things
that i disagree with and i haven't seen
a single one
come at me that i've agreed with there's
been like one that i was somewhat okay
with i thought was kind of cool
no this is the game i'm making
um yeah there's been one
sponsorship that's been offered that i
thought uh maybe but the pay was so low
that i i didn't take it it was it didn't
seem quite worth it it was
barely anything basically and it would
have been a lot of work it would have i
would have made less than
the
video cost to produce basically so it's
just like what's the point
i don't know honesty doesn't always pay
and uh maybe i should be a sellout but i
just refuse i never have wanted to be
i've always been like this causes some
stress within people in my life that i
won't do what they say even if they pay
me but
it is what it is all right well that's
it hope you guys consider supporting i
love doing this and uh i'm gonna try to
keep bringing you cool stuff in the
meantime i'm gonna be working on my own
stuff
and uh take care guys peace
you